Oh No so I take again multiple times
because I'm bad and very very sorry for
any just can't get a break
okay Cody good job we broke your leg out
of the starting gate Donald um really
yeah I murdered a kid just as he was
trying to eat his fruits its vegetables
Jamie Neon Neon ball throw well I'm just
wondering out oh that was very close to
the wind I'm just what you know what
squish mean oh no I'm falling whoa can't
kill me now
Travis again Oh
but I'm still alive nananananana
I have no fee I've gotten every of the
no don't let me get stale predict me Oh
red neon course spikes level ones all
right trying this again all right trying
it again not getting killed by the
spikes there's a way to bend all there
was a way to bend my knees oh that
should have been haha can't get me and
I'm the gingerbread man oh yeah just
like over there Oh can't get me were you
aiming for my balls when you're a winner
okay don't know what the hell happened
over there but I don't want to know how
does a watermelon L may it doesn't you
blocked me from winning you dick I'm
very close to the winner's circle can
you not interrupt me I do not need this
many bowls oh by the way die low wha
what am i doing where am i what am i
doing I hope I'm crafting again you seen
it I can't get out where am I going
what happened
wow what is a magical kill you machine
okay take two I think yeah okay I was
just supposed to go forward not any
other mystical magical way just forward
[Music]
okay there we go
you hit me so hard my computer froze now
and get through the chocolate pounders
here all right take again this time
let's not lose our hands some what are
those hand removal devices kid run run
kid run you can still make it run oh
you're dead candy take 500 trusty Candy
Man can candy man filled you with death
and destruction to make your life feels
bad oh look I'm making it ha ha ha you
can't get me your big candy crusher
bastards 99.4% impossible let's see what
that really put up your dukes I'm ready
just as soon as they stop walking
backwards any minute now
gonna just stretch them is there some
danger here ready to fight crime hmm
someone's killed these [ __ ] well
they look like they deserved it but I'll
carry on if I could move forward
if I could move forward I was wonder did
you kill them [ __ ] you got him
good job me time for a break dance yeah
[Music]
oh boy look at all these lovely
employees who are also working here care
to join me in the air okay happy
thoughts to hit my arms and legs back
ah so you're looking at me funny JP but
this is for your music this for being a
douche those were all your crappy music
again
there now you fans over there take that
three in one dear I may be an old man
but I'm a sassy old man who does a quad
good thing I'm a sensible woman who
don't need no man or wings to fly Bob I
got the baby in the kiddie ride away
kitty
run from here oh oh oh you decide come
with me Our Lady that's just like you
yeah you take that kid get him out here
oh I thought that was gonna be instant
death for me falling through the sky now
ow my arm ripped off there right there
but somehow I
how about Segway cars you gonna be a
high I can get my face there's no lunch
limo anywhere Oh what happened
ho go I don't think Pogo was meant for
this okay oh come on I'm gonna cheat cuz
cheating is the way to be still oh this
is the last character left no no WWE
mortals to do okay grab it okay don't
take three
my back don't leave without me I'm just
gonna breakdance for you just a little
bit you relax here while I do things -
apparently I really not trying to I'm
not trying to do this please understand
I'm really not trying to do this I don't
want to do this
snot no wonder this guy don't hump him
well I mean splitting a mouth is another
way god damn it I don't know what you're
doing that kid but I am too all right no
okay
not death if there's a win right here
please tell me that's not a troll just
once just once I would love to win
Hunger Games okay I'm just gonna carry
on on my way cuz I'm Katniss ever done
not Katniss Everdeen cuz I'm a man okay
just gonna move on from that don't want
to know what you're doing over there oh
no okay
I blew them up with my mind powers cuz
I'm Katniss ever done okay I'm beginning
to think that my name is not the
weirdest thing going on here even though
I'm Ken toilet run not really what I
would call Orthodox but okay
who it said markiplier hey whoever made
this you're welcome ain't thank you
you're welcome for me being awesome
you're welcome to enjoy my awesomeness
kill or be killed
okay that was easy oh what's that
I seem to speared you by your balls
right doesn't seem so fun now does it
oh no no kill him kill who
kill him where oh I think I'm doing
something else to him kill him I miss
oh well since you're here no God why
it's the sword that works
alright you [ __ ]
let's not rush rush down door are you
Curtis this one's only four this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you liked the video and want
to see more why not subscribe today want
to help the channel grow leave a like
and then to your favorites will share
with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video